the destruction in this small kentucky
town is breathtaking
it was dark when the tornado reached
mayfield and with sunrise the loss was
so horribly clear
homes businesses and many lives
it is the sustained strength of the
storm system that is so remarkable just
look at this its power brought down
brick buildings it churned up vehicles
well the level of destruction here in
the heart of the town really is
absolutely extraordinary just take a
look at that building there
almost completely destroyed will almost
certainly have to be rebuilt and
everywhere you look around the center of
the town it is the same the sun's going
down now and people are
are coming out to survey
and take in their town destroyed
[Music]
there was some warning that a storm was
coming but it wasn't just one it was a
series of tornadoes across six states
at the fire station in mayfield the fire
chief had asked his team to stay as the
storm hit they did and they now wonder
how they survived the building was
shaking the lights were going off there
was debris flying everywhere have you
ever experienced anything like that
before never in my life
this is uh it's uh
it was one of the scariest uh
scariest few minutes of my life the
rescue and recovery here is all the more
tricky because the station itself had
the roof ripped off
we're committed to serving our community
we're not going to stop until
everybody's accounted for and everybody
that we can help can is help
driving around the town it is remarkable
more people were not lost
but at the local candle factory they are
still searching for many missing
it had been full with night shift
workers meeting the christmas demand
and those who made it are reflecting
the lights went out and then we did a
rock
rock
rock
boom and everything fell down on us
there are communities who've been hit
like this across several states from
north to south the length of the country
a series of tornadoes has ripped life
and livelihood apart and at a time when
so many have been struggling already
mark stone sky news in mayfield kentucky